when we first encounter roderica she
comes off as a scared underwhelming
character we find her in the stormhill
shack just outside of stormville castle
where she tells us that she's afraid to
be subject to the grafting process
grafting in elden ring is the process of
detaching limbs from the body of a
tarnished and reattaching those limbs to
another we can see the results of
grafting when we fight the grafted
scions and of course godric the grafted
from roderica's dialogue we can see that
she's been brought here from outside the
lands between
everyone who came with me
they crossed the sea for me they fought
for me
only to have their arms taken
their legs taken even their heads
taken
taken and stuck
to the spider she then goes on to
insinuate that the grafting process is
somewhat normal telling us that she just
wants to be like everybody else
it's scary you know having your arms cut
off
or legs
or your head
i want to be like everyone else but i'm
just too scared
i'm nothing but a craven
so we can assume from this that roderica
and the rest of the tarnish where they
traveled from have given up on trying to
become elden lord the tarnished have
been resurrected after the shattering of
the elden ring in order to seek out the
shard bearers collect the great runes
and mend the elden ring back together so
venturing to the lands between only to
have your body parts cut off and
attached to this freak of nature
definitely doesn't seem like the hopeful
actions of someone trying to become
elden lord she confirms this with us
when we see her again at the round table
hold where she tells us that she
couldn't ever be strong enough to become
elden lord and is seeking a new purpose
instead the round table hold
cover quarters of the two fingers
and gathering place of champions who vie
to become elder lord i never knew the
guidance bestowed upon us tarnished had
such fantastic roots
although
it's all a bit much for me in truth
i'm still looking for my own purpose
we then talk to the blacksmith huge and
can ask him about roderica
she's crestfallen and can scarcely swing
a blade
but she has a gift
for spirit tuning
i saw another one like how long ago
their eyes share the same hue
he mentions to us that he once knew a
spirit tuner who had a similar eye color
or hue to rodericka this then opens up
the most interesting question we can ask
about roderica who is hugh talking about
who is this spirit tuner similar to her
we know that huge has likely been
sentenced to serve the round table hold
under the order of queen america he was
also given the power or has already the
ability to smith weapons capable of
killing a god we can see that huge is
doing everything in his power to do what
queen america wants and is terrified of
her
given time
technique never fails
besides it helps me forget
the sheer terror of her
and even when the round table starts to
burn down and the other characters start
to leave huge stays at the round table
hold regardless of this even after his
chain breaks he still stays the smith
weapons for us he goes on to tell us
about how he feels regarding his
imprisonment as you've noticed to james
nothing special
i'm a prisoner and these are my chains
i'm trapped by the hold
i'm dying smithing for you fools
don't read too much into it well no
grudge against you
my being a prisoner is no fault of yours
in my opinion i think hugh chained
himself to the wall in order to keep him
there and do the bidding of queen merica
and the tarnished of the round table
hold he believes he has done something
so horrible to the wishes of queen
america that he must do whatever it
takes to make it up to her but why would
hugh be asking for forgiveness from
queen america what did he do it seems as
though hugh's determination to smith
weapons is potentially a deal he has
made with queen america herself he wants
her forgiveness but what could huge have
done to upset queen america this much
well i think this takes us back to the
question of who is the spirit tuner he
relates to roderica the only character
that i can find that has similar eyes to
rodericas is ronnie they both have a
greenish bluish hue to their eyes that
are vastly different from the rest of
the characters and when you think about
it more it could make sense that huge is
referring to ronnie she is the first
person that introduces us to the spirit
calling bell and is herself a spirit
after she decided to kill her own
imperian flesh and become only a spirit
which takes over the doll we see as
ronnie which is where i believe hugh
once met ronnie also a fun little side
note here when you do first speak to
ronnie in the church of ella you can see
that kalei and even his donkey are
asleep put under some type of spell by
ronnie i just thought this was a cool
little detail it's entirely possible
that hugh is the blacksmith that created
the daggers used in the night of black
knives and helped infuse the daggers
with a fragment of the rune of death
that ronnie stole from malaketh hugh's
contribution to the knight of black
knives could be what queen america was
upset about as we all know at this point
america is a very cunning queen and the
plan she has created to defy the greater
will runs very deep so instead of just
killing hugue she instead decides to use
huge for his amazing smithing abilities
america knew that the tarnish would need
a blacksmith to help them on their
journey so she sent hugh to the round
table to smith weapons capable of
killing a god for the tarnished we know
he's capable of this because well he
makes our weapons that we use to kill
many demigods and eventually the
manifestation of the greater will the
elden beast this is huge's purpose this
is why he's praying for her forgiveness
so he can make up for his contribution
in the night of black knives whether he
knew it or not and served queen
america's will i believe hugh likely
didn't know of ronnie's true intentions
with these daggers and is every day
trying to make up for his mistake by
constantly smithing weapons for the
tarnished which brings me to my next
point listen to what hugh says about
this spirit tuner
she has a gift for spiritunity
so i told her everything i know
i'm indebted to a spirit tuner i met
long ago
it was all i could do to honor her
after listening to this why would hugh
continue to feel indebted to the spirit
tuner if he was ultimately used by
ronnie for the night of black knives and
is now trying to earn america's
forgiveness well as most of us know at
this point the ronnie we see is just a
doll it isn't really what ronnie looks
like we can see ronnie's real body at
the top of the carrion divine tower the
doll ronnie uses is meant to represent
her teacher known as renna so it's much
more likely that huge thought ronnie was
rena when she asked him to create the
black knives we know that ronnie uses
this alias of rena all the time as our
initial introduction to her was under
this alias
a pleasure to meet the tarnished
i am the witch rena
ronnie uses rena's name to either hide
her true identity or to manipulate
others who only know the reputation of
rena so when hugh sees rodericka he
initially sees a resemblance to rena
just from the hue of her eyes in an
effort to yet again make up for what he
has done he takes rodericka under his
wing teaching her the practice of spirit
tuning that he likely first learned or
at least observed from rena this truly
shows how every character we meet in
this game has a deep purpose and
possible connection to so many others in
this game it also shows us that there
are many characters that we just don't
know a ton about yet we'll likely have
to wait for some major dlc updates for
us to learn more about rena the rabbit
hole the lore of elden ring goes down is
truly incredible we will likely be
discovering new connections and making
theories for years to come i'd like to
take a moment to thank and give a shout
out to an incredible artist named andrea
gardino he has kindly let me use some of
his elden ring artwork in some of my
thumbnails and his work is absolutely
beautiful he does a lot more than just
elden ring so if you're interested in
some of his art i'll be leaving a link
to his website and to his twitter where
he currently has his commissions open so
go get yourself some amazing artwork
from him i can't wait to see what else
he creates and i absolutely love his art
style thank you all for watching the
video make sure to subscribe if you want
to and i'll see you in the next video
take care